because that was not a normal song yeah
but then like Ed Sheeran's is just a
slow ballad with the freaking you know
like it's like all of his songs it
doesn't share characteristics it only
shares chord progression which is
different didn't Ken just get busted for
copying a bunch of Millie Vanilli dance
moves
Millie Vanilli
[Music]
ant so is anybody familiar or caught up
with uh Ed Sheeran's uh trial oh yeah
ongoing just ended against the Marvin
gayest yeah wait what happened against
the Marvin Gaye's thing no no no no they
were suing him yeah co-writers of Marvin
Gaye's Let's Get It On yeah uh we're
suing Ed Sheeran for plagiarism for his
song Thinking Out Loud have you heard
that why do you think it sounds alike
nope I don't you know yeah let's let's
consult the uh musician here so I I
think it sounds similar what are the two
songs can you help me I forgot what the
do do do do do do do do
that's the freaking nature that's Marvin
Gaye so yeah come on come on come on
come on darling stop being around the
booze
those two are similar no they have
similar chord progressions they have
similar chord progressions but those
chords have been around since the
beginning of time yeah we need we need
here an actual music position talk about
like what constitutes plagiarism and
also the context of like same thing like
musician it's like uh I I could speak on
it and dance at the end of the day we
all have the same two arms and two legs
there's only so many types of
combinations to try and rework movement
but like from a musician's point of view
like what what is the basis for it it's
there's no way you can it's it's enough
to be able to State the case but it's
not enough to make it winnable because
the Robin Thicke song and the Marvin
Gaye one it sounds very similar
that one was conceptually similar
because they had like little things here
and there that were like almost like the
way they made this almost sounded like a
tribute to that yeah it's like parody
yeah that was not a normal song yeah but
then like Ed Sheeran's is just a slow
ballad with the freaking you know like
it's like all of his songs it doesn't
share characteristics it only shares
chord progression which is different
didn't Kendra's get busted for copying a
bunch of Millie Vanilli dance moves
okay
OG lip syncers oh Millie Vanilli dance
moves that is the craziest
[Laughter]
did they do like New Jack Swing style it
was 90s yeah and then they went like
this a lot
obviously our secret signature
trademarks it looks like you guys yeah
yeah but it's it's it shares chord it
shares similar chords but you can't put
trademarks or anything on chords
so it doesn't make sense and that's
ultimately what happened when you say
similar chords are they the same chord
progression like the same at some points
they're similar
they're not exactly the same and they
don't always stay in that same order
like so like let's get it on has a
bridge that Ed Sheeran song has no
similarities to whatsoever uh uh but
then it's it's on those those little
hooks that they're like oh see we put
them side by side and they're kind of
but you can do that with so many songs
that's how people make medleys right
they kind of are all in the same key and
they kind of like oh that Sound flow so
that song absolutely yeah absolutely do
you think that because Marvin Gaye's not
making music anymore the family is like
we need likes angles Lula I mean I think
I think they got a little heady after
they won that last one um who do they
win against like Robin Thicke yeah they
want to and they basically want a lot of
money so they're coming after everybody
kind of business model number it seems
like because of that maybe they're like
oh we can get this too so if you're a
music lawyer or you gotta you gotta be
able to play the keys and be good at law
yeah you gotta know it all right because
you got to be able to be like oh legally
uh-huh uh-huh okay yeah yep yeah they
won uh they won 5.3 million dollars from
that that sheesh I think when the when
they do those copyright laws and and
Court the lawyer also busts out a Casio
yeah and he starts playing the keys did
you ever see uh The Boondocks episode
where R Kelly's on yeah and then they're
like to stay this case they just throw
him a mic and he performs
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what did you think of the Robin Thicke
song versus um I I thought it's shared
characteristics I was surprised that
that happened though that it won yeah I
was surprised but I think it was just
too maybe it was just close enough that
the jury was sometimes you know like in
the 70s I feel like the bands should sue
themselves
like you'll follow like like barcays or
whatever right like a funk band or even
[__] like Lakeside they got five
songs that sound the same yeah I'm like
bro you need to sue yourself
[__] you don't have any original
creatures to the [__]
every single sounds like higher
creatures chew themselves into Oblivion
dude
so should the two unlimited the ones
that go
every song they have is that yeah is it
really yeah that's the name of the band
I've always want to know what those
[__] sounded like yeah I was
surprised at that that one but the the
thing is it did share similar like it
was the conceptual side they were like
listen to like how it has this like the
little dingy thing like there's so much
about it that seemed like it was trying
to recreate that yeah but then this is
like Ed Sheeran said he's gonna quit
music if this if he lost yeah he
literally promised to quit the music
industry all together if he was found
guilty of plagiarizing the song because
it's ridiculous because he was saying
too like it's it's hard to you have to
be creative halfway
remembering that like oh I can't be too
creative where I think I'm making this
up and I get sued like that's it's
really hard it's unsustainable there's
something like that takes the artist out
of something when they become litigious
like this yeah exactly it's kind of
weird right because like you would think
that like in a community right of
dancers or like even like singers or
whatever like you're kind of sharing and
stealing from each other all the time
like how many [__] movies are exactly
the same movie as another movie right
like I don't get the everything's
derivative right but then if you can
prove that it was maliciously driven I
think it's different yeah but in this
case it's just there's only so many
chords man especially if you're making
pop hits do you think that people that
are taking over Marvin Gaye's estate you
think they're a little toxic in the
music world you think everyone's looking
at them like definitely [__] these guys
I think I think it is because it's one
thing if like with the Robin Thicke
thing I can understand a little bit if
there's some kind of emotional like
response to hey you're taking this man's
Legacy and this sound and you're ripping
that off I understand that this is just
hey that sounds a little bit like this
and I'll stretch it to prove it nobody
thought when they heard Thinking Out
Loud that like hey this is like that
Marvin Gaye song like nobody said that
because imagine if Ed Sheeran had a song
that sounded like Marvin Gaye you know
he's none of the song Sonic Marvel gay I
would I think it would be so funny if Ed
Sheeran started making songs that
intentionally sound like Marvin Gaye
should double down you know who's good
at me I make songs that sound like other
songs but they do such a good job Bruno
Mars oh yeah yeah like he makes songs
that sound like that era because he
captured the Moorish day feel yeah yeah
yeah and like that like that kind of
like a high class Pimpin feel yeah and
but then didn't actually rip the song
structure it was just like made that
yeah like every song he makes like oh
he's doing that era or this era or this
era it's funny too because like then you
got weird out literally ripping the
entire song and just parroting it
because it's over at parody he can do it
and he can sell it yeah and he survived
more than all the artists he parodies
yeah his career outlives everyone he's
making fun of it's crazy Amish Paradise
right that's a good one that was a good
one but yeah Coolio had that and like
what else like yeah exactly is that just
like protected under parody law all of
it yeah because it's parody it's intense
parody the intentions yeah versus life
does he have to get clearance though I
think he he doesn't but he says that he
likes to get a blessed yeah because I
know that on a I think on a talk show
once they were asking him like who's
someone that said said no and I think
like maybe Prince is one of them or
someone else because Prince takes
himself but he just won't do it so
you're saying no if they're but then I
think he was so people just like him
that they're like yeah go for it yeah it
probably helps their song yeah yeah when
you get a a Weird Al Paris yeah oh by
the way just as a little tidbit fun
thing when you make a remix of a song
like uh let's say you have like a pop
hit and a bunch of people start making
remixes of them all right if you
sanction those remixes if you say like
oh I like what uh Diplo did with my song
you can sanction that in every sale that
he gets counts as a sale for your album
for the song statistically but not
financially so if you see that somebody
went triple platinum that includes every
remix that was made for that song
probably made a lot of platinum in the
club in the club you got so many remixes
off that yeah so sometimes Blues in the
music industry yeah so sometimes when
you start seeing all these remixes you
can go oh that one's good I like that
one I like that one then you can it goes
under the umbrella of your sale even if
people aren't buying the original what
would Ed Sheeran have done if he had to
quit music become a leprechaun
impersonator
in Mobile Alabama that's a really good
idea Joe just I did a tree yeah even if
you quit making new music his numbers
are so [__] big that like he could
just live off the royalties of
everything he's already working anymore
yeah but at that point you're already
rich right so what else do you have to
live for if you're a musician and you're
a creative person leprechaun
impersonators
that's a whole other Niche they should
have a Lucky Charms festival and he
could be the master of ceremony you know
the red fair dude Live It Up really good
yeah if he quick quits music right yeah
so not even anywhere because like what's
that guy's name Trent rezner Nine Inch
Nails he scores movies now right but
he's still but he's still in music yeah
because I could totally see Ed Sheeran
scoring music but then what is he gonna
do though like MMA now or like you know
they don't have leprechaun MMA yeah but
what's his next thing he'll find
Hospital start driving right it could be
something else you know I would be sad
to see someone quit music over a reason
like this it's breaking their heart
especially someone like him it feels
like Ketchum I don't give a [__] dude I
wish you quit right now because Ed
Sheeran's not like ready to retire yet
he's still in his Prime when he's
creating content yeah kind of just blew
up blew up right like I think he really
started blowing up maybe like 2015. and
a lot of the hits I hear from other
artists um well that's a good song and I
find out that Ed wrote it so I'm like so
I'm like
um what's that what's up with Justin
Bieber
I don't know that one I don't like that
song you should you should love yourself
that one yeah yeah like the like I like
the message my mom loves I hates you but
she likes everybody like whatever yeah
he wrote that song he also was like the
first guy to like outsell like uh you
two in like the UK good yeah Big Willy's
Style
just in terms of like his pop stature
he's like you two doesn't count because
wasn't it like how do I have this song I
hated it that made me hate you too okay
what's a good song for my uh YouTube
That's not how no they didn't give us a
beautiful day no you gave us some whack
out dude they finally apologized for
doing that but it started playing every
time I got in my car I was like why the
[__] is always a beautiful day you know
they apologize formally for doing that I
took out I don't use apple music for
that same [__] reason but he is
though I use Spotify like what if what
do you do on Spotify you just got forced
E40 albums yeah yeah that's better
that's better than you too sprinkle me
baby big on forgiveness I think
forgiveness is good but I don't I don't
forgive them
they put like 51 songs on that album
that was insane a lot yeah I don't need
the deluxe version okay yeah just give
me the regular ones but yeah they didn't
give us a beautiful day that's not them
no
litigation sucks for music it sucks too
that like probably back when the
original Marvin Gaye songs were
happening the chances of being sued for
copying probably weren't as high as they
are now like it feels like that's
something they probably didn't have to
deal with in today's culture
pretty pretty much dude imagine you
imagine you have a band and and all the
people around you they're just like you
two you two holy [__] holy [__] and you
just think that you're so tight and your
music is so sick that when you give it
to everyone for free as a present
they're all gonna be like oh my God
thank you you two and I said everyone's
like hey [__] you guys
dude that's so funny
[__]
[Music]
thank you